you made a tweet recently um which was  pretty controversial rapist as sex as  fiat is to bitcoin something like that  yeah i was accused of trivializing rape  i was also accused of making a category  error and that i should never compare  these two things but the difference  between sex and rape is consent the  difference between a transaction and  theft is consent the power to say no is  the root of sovereignty you can't if you  don't have the power to say no if  someone's physically coercing you over  your attestation to the contrary like  stop no i want to leave then that's a  non-consensual exchange and you're in  the realm of immorality and evil there  were 169 million people murdered in the  20th century by states fiat funded  states i'll say that again 169  million people murdered in the 20th  century by fiat funded states i know  rape is bad  that's pretty bad too the leopon show